[Music]
welcome back to science click today
black holes space-time in which we live
can be conceptualized as a grid any
object which possesses a mass distorts
space-time forming around it a
gravitational well if another object is
closeby then it will get attracted and
spiral down the gravitational well like
a marble in a bowl the greater the mass
of the object the stronger the
attraction and the quicker the attracted
object must move to free itself from the
gravitational pull if the mass of the
object becomes huge without the object
growing in size then the gravitational
well created will be so great that the
speed required to escape it would be
greater than the speed of light since
nothing can move faster than the speed
of light then nothing will be able to
escape this attraction even light if it
gets too close will be captured this is
a black hole
at its core a black hole holds a
gravitational singularity this is a
point in space at which the curvature of
space-time becomes infinite the further
we move away from this singularity the
weak of the gravitational pull once we
reach a limit known as the event horizon
the gravitational pull becomes weak
enough for light passing by to escape
the black hole as such all entities
outside the horizon can hope to escape
the black hole but as soon as an object
moves within the horizon it is destined
to fall into the black hole without ever
being able to come back since black
holes swallow up any light that gets too
close they appear black to us and as
such cannot be seen directly nonetheless
they can be detected indirectly firstly
their presence is given away by their
strong gravitational influence since
they are capable of deviating light the
lack COEs effectively behave like
gravitational lenses which deviate the
trajectory of light rays coming from far
away stars thus creating a gravitational
Mirage since they have a strong
influence from far away black holes can
also be identified by looking at the
trajectories of stars close by finally
even though black holes do not emit any
sort of radiation themselves they do
emit some indirectly indeed around
certain black holes attracted
surrounding matter will form a disc
rotating around the singularity this
disc by rotating at high speeds will
warm up and emit X and gamma rays which
are relatively straightforward to detect
there exist in the universe black holes
of all sorts of size the smallest ones
known as stellar black holes are caused
by the collapse of massive stars with
the size of only a few kilometers they
nonetheless have a mass several times
greater than our Sun the largest black
holes are found at the center of
galaxies ours included these
supermassive black holes are enormous
reaching several billion kilometres in
size finally while black holes cannot
emit radiation complex quantum effects
result in every black hole evaporating
slowly emitting a certain unique type of
radiation which we call Hawking's
radiation the larger a black hole the
more time it would take to evaporate as
such for normal sized black holes this
evaporation is extremely slow spread out
over billions of years and therefore of
little importance to us however there
could well exist microscopic black holes
which might have formed following the
Big Bang for these primordial black
holes the evaporation phenomenon would
be very important leading to an almost
instantaneous disappearance
black holes are complex objects full of
mystery and which continued to feed
scientific imagination they have given
rise to many questions and hypotheses
such as the existence of shortcuts which
could enable us to travel through
space-time wormholes
[Music]
[Music]